so just before we get into the video
today i just want to say thank you to
everyone for supporting me on this
journey i guess so far we hit 10k subs i
think it was like two days after my 24th
birthday as well so it was extremely
cool to finally hit that massive
milestone and i just want to say thank
you to all of you guys as you've
supported me throughout this entire way
so far especially a specific few of you
who know who you are who have been with
me almost the entire journey so far so i
just want to say thank you to you know
everyone that has been here and enjoys
my content as this is an absolute dream
of mine that is coming true like
honestly before my eyes and sometimes i
kind of just have to sit back and
realize that this is all kind of
happening like so extremely quickly that
i don't even realize that it's happening
and going from getting a hundred views
or 200 views on a video two months ago
to now having you know two videos with
over a hundred thousand views or two
videos with over a hundred and fifty
thousand views and even one over two
hundred thousand it just blows my mind
the absolute support that you guys have
given me is
is paramount and i can't thank you all
enough for it it's been an absolutely
amazing journey so far and for that i
put out a q a on my community tab asking
you guys to chuck down a whole bunch of
questions that i guess you've wanted to
ask me throughout my entire journey so
far and i'll answer them throughout this
video if you guys want to see like more
videos like this and stuff where i kind
of answer your questions and do all that
kind of stuff be sure to let me know
down in the comment section below as
perhaps we could do this at every like
milestone like next at 15k perhaps and
then again at 20 or 20k and then at 30k
do them every 10k or something like that
i'd love to know what you guys think so
just be sure to comment down below so i
guess we're going to start off with
moria k who's asked since you've been
doing a lot of tokyo avengers videos i
have some questions who's your favorite
tokyo avengers character and why what
got you into reading manga and what are
some hobbies of yours favorite anime
slash manga and congrats
or obviously uh i'm gonna have a lot of
questions throughout this video i
thought i'd just mention this now as
well so i'm not gonna be able to answer
them super in-depth but perhaps in the
future we can go more in depth on some
of these ideas my favorite tokyo
avengers character is probably takamichi
and why just because we've stuck with
him throughout the entire series so far
and we've been able to see him grow from
this like i guess you could say immature
afraid 26 year old man who doesn't
really know his way in life to now
having a certain goal that he can
constantly fight for and i just think
it's quite courageous of him how he's
never backed down and i just i honestly
just love him as a character so what got
me into reading manga honestly is
probably the best answer there is
actually tower of god so i started
reading manga maybe about two years ago
now and i started with actually a manual
which is obviously tower of god and that
was because i watched the first season
of terror of god that was on crunchyroll
and enjoyed it so much that i picked up
the manual for it and i've read about
i think 350 chapters of that now what
are some hobbies of mine well honestly i
absolutely love gaming and kind of just
hanging out with my mates and chilling
out and discord i really don't do too
much outside of the house i guess i
would love to you know do some stuff in
the future for my channel if i could
like going out to stores and buying some
stuff if that's possible i'm not too
sure if i'll ever do a face reveal type
thing but um yeah i have honestly just
been gaming for the last few years
that's like one of my biggest hobbies
for sure next from keith speaks we have
who's your favorite member of tomen and
why do you pick diavolo over every other
jojo character well i can't really say i
wanted to be different and pick diavolo
because no one knows who he is in joju's
or something i honestly just really
loved his entrance and the entire aura
that he had around him as a character i
thought it was extremely mysterious and
i guess for the fact of diavolo as well
is the idea that you guys don't know
what i look like and no one knew what
divolo looked like and i thought it was
a great comparison on how diavolo's this
you know like hidden figurine i also am
in some kind of way i know i just i just
really love the comparison for it the
fake weave asks congrats on 10k bro for
real your goal was 5k by the end of the
year and you doubled that quickly glad
to see your channels popping off thank
you dude means a lot honestly coming
from someone who was quadruple my size
when i first started making content and
someone who you know i've watched
previously in the past so now thank you
dude it means a lot coming from you uh
question what's your favorite anime and
manga so my favorite anime it's an
extremely hard question because i don't
really like i always change from what i
have as a favorite constantly i don't
know how to put that but like i always
say this is my specific favorite or this
is my specific favorite so it's very
hard for me to always pin down uh
something that is my favorite but
something that i've enjoyed the most
probably and it's hard to base it off in
every episode enjoyment factor but for
middle alchemist brotherhood is
something that i kind of always consider
to be in my top three for favorite anime
and manga i've only read a few but at
the moment it's probably either one
piece or tokyo revenges probably one of
the two they're both extremely amazing
mangas so you know i recommend anyone to
pick them up if you haven't already
sakura asks favorite tokyo revenge's arc
and also where did you get your accent
from just curious
so
um my favorite tokyo avengers arc is
probably the black dragon's arc or
it's har it's really hard for me to pick
between the black dragons are and the
tnjiku arc i don't really know why
they're just both amazing arcs in my
mind and i am from new zealand if you
guys are wondering so that's my accent
it's a kiwi accent with a hardcore
online influence from a lot of
australian dudes so it doesn't exactly
sound kiwi all the time but um majority
of the time it sounds pretty kiwi
sometimes i sound australian carlos art
asks what other plans do you have for
the future of the channel so for the
future of the channel i'd really like to
honestly stretch out and do other series
as well as tokyo avengers the anime has
ended for now so i'm probably going to
you know stick with reviewing that
weekly i really want to start doing more
death type videos that i've done for the
tokyo avengers one but perhaps through
different series or even doing the
entire series of like a bunch of
different anime uh that people or a
bunch of different manga that people
want to see kind of put into a full
story so that you could watch it on my
channel so yeah if you guys want to see
more of that let me know in the comment
section below is that something that
i've been thinking about doing so like
the entire naruto story or the entire
baruto story type thing as an example
next we have shiftic who's asked does
making a chapter review ever feel like a
chore to you if so what keeps you
motivated i guess it can sometimes like
when i don't exactly want to to talk and
i just want to sit there and watch a
video perhaps but it's more or less you
know like once i get into the groove of
it i kind of really enjoy what i'm
talking about so i continue on and kind
of just mumble about what i'm saying
especially when the new chapter is
exciting uh it makes it all the better
when the chapter is a bit dull it can be
a bit dull sometimes but apart from that
no i don't really ever feel like too
demotivated at all or haven't so far but
then again i've only been doing this for
like four months at the moment so it
hasn't been too long next we have sam
chong big congrats been watching you for
a bit and happy to see that you've
reached this milestone what's the anime
and manga that you have wanted to watch
but haven't gotten to yet oh that's a
very good question a manga that i
haven't gone to yet is a hundred percent
berserk or
vagabond those are two that i that i
really really want to read but i just
haven't had the time for drew brown asks
since your account has grown so quickly
have you considered doing youtube
full-time like possibly as a career well
absolutely like this is my honest you
know like this is my dream this is
something that i've wanted to do since i
was 15 or 16 years old and uploaded
minecraft videos on this exact channel
where i used to play uh hunger games and
stuff but sadly down around anymore
because they deleted them a few years
ago i think the only one that is is the
100k view texture pack that i had but
that's from when i was 16 but it's
something that i've wanted to do for
years so after i went to university and
started working i realized that i kind
of wish i didn't stop uploading content
on youtube and i wish i kind of stuck at
it so to have this kind of blow up now
is something that i can't explain it's
so
amazing to me and it
gives me this really extremely warm
feeling inside that i really can't
explain to most people because this is
an actual dream of mine that is really
coming true and it's really really hard
for me to put into words how amazing
this is so as i've already said to you
guys thank you it's making me tear up
just talking about it so
yeah but yeah to finish your christian
drew i would absolutely love to do this
like as a career if i ever could the
next question we have is from anonymous
who was asking if hisaki was alive in
this ongoing ark what will be his plans
your thoughts so i think i've said it in
a chapter review or a spoiler video
before but i think if kisaki was still
alive in this timeline he'd be with
hanma who i suspect hanuma is part of
the rokuharatandai and is actually the
leader currently of the rokuharatandai
at the north rokuharatando that is as
we've seen we've got the leader of the
south that we've seen as toronto but we
haven't seen a north leader and in
japanese culture there is a a north
rokuhara that is uh known as well as the
south rokuhara so it's just it makes
sense for there to be a north part of it
perhaps or at least in my eyes it does
so maybe that's where kisaki would
possibly be with hanma uh messing around
and kind of scheming to try and take
mikey's empire from him luke banwell the
man himself asks golf with friends
tournament win well maybe one day hit
everyone in my discord and we could have
a massive golf with friends tournament
or something like that with a bit of
money online it could be quite fun could
be quite fun check it out my channel let
me know if you guys want to see that if
you play golf for friends you know jump
in the discord kid static asks how can i
give you recommendations recommendations
wise feel free to join my discord which
i will leave a link to in the comment
section below and i'll pin it as the top
comment for you guys and just click on
that link and join the discord and and
there is a recommendations there for
anime and manga and just other videos in
general uh sadpug asks have you ever
read or watched you do hacker show no i
haven't read or watched it but obviously
sensei inc has given me all the hype
around the series and it's something
that i'm probably going to watch down
the line as well when i have time it's
kind of just about when i get time to do
specific things there's so much that i
do want to watch i've just got to slowly
get my way through all of it razer asks
any plans on making a theory video on
jjk about sakuna especially possibly in
the future i think at the moment i'm
kind of just waiting for more stuff to
happen throughout this coloring game arc
to really make a theory i've got a
theory at the moment on how i think
carrara hoshi's technique works exactly
in relation to the stars
uh i know we did get an explanation from
megami obviously but i definitely will
be making uh more jjk content in the
future especially as the uh the movie if
i just shoot 2000 and the anime start to
come back out again and it gets that uh
resurgence again netlan asks what will
you do with your channel once tokyo
avengers is completed it's a pretty good
question well i think in general i was
doing a lot of spoiler and review
content for one piece and jjk but i kind
of want to stretch out and start making
just more videos in general about anime
that i kind of enjoy and just like
watching so that's why down the line i
want to make a lot more of those you
know entire
lore videos of specific series and then
also a lot of the death videos for
specific series because i just love
going over climactic moments throughout
series they have a lot of hype behind
them and i really enjoy them pixel dino
asks i know most questions are anime and
stuff so i wanted to ask something
different do you play any games and if
you do or used to which are your
favorite so i have played a bunch of
games i absolutely love
cs go and at the moment i'm playing
conan with a whole bunch of my mates and
stuff so i yeah i do play games all the
time it's kind of just what i do in my
spare time instead of heading out and
going to town and spending my money on
stuff in town i'd rather spend it on i
guess video games to play with my mates
uh spectre asks what's your favorite
gang logo and tokyo avengers hmm
it's a good one it's a really good one
um i really like the simplicity of the
valhalla logo with the headless angel in
the wings yeah i think that's probably
my favorite uh logo in tokyo avengers
for sure icy hot asks what country are
you from so obviously new zealand uh
what's your real name so my real name is
cody and what's your favorite anime
which i think i've answered earlier
throughout the video but if not it's
probably like hanahana or for me to
alchemist brotherhood naruto or
something like that something a little
bit older but it's you know it's
something that i got into when i was a
little bit younger and what got me into
making youtube videos honestly i'm not
gonna lie probably i was in between work
a lot of stuff had happened in my
personal life and i really didn't know
where i was headed so i started to make
content on youtube where i'd make amvs
and upload them because i really enjoyed
watching amvs and i guess over time i
just started to upload things that i've
always watched on youtube so i've always
watched rain videos so i've listened to
rain videos at night so at one point i
uploaded rain videos to see you know if
that would work out for me and you know
here i am now with the anime stuff which
is working because this is something
that done for the last i don't know
eight or nine years now is just watching
anime content on youtube so i didn't
expect this to to work by any means but
a lot of anime and youtubers in general
is just what got me into making videos
you asks congrats on 10k and how old are
you so i just turned 24 years old as of
like the 8th of september if you guys
are curious speed the daggerbird goat
wagon asks yes sir 20k by the end of the
year uh 100 bro like let's do it maybe i
don't i don't want to jinx myself i
don't want jinx myself maybe we'll get
there hopefully hopefully oh excel asks
saddest jujutsu kaizen death probably
nanami's death i would say just for the
fact that if it wasn't for nanami's
death i honestly don't think i'd be
making anime videos as well because i
wanted to make a video on an army and
that was the first video i'm pretty sure
i made on my channel anime wise was the
nanami one and then i spoiled myself on
his death and started reading a lot more
manga because of it so honestly i don't
think i'd be here if it wasn't for what
i i consider the saddest juicy and death
i have no idea how to say this person's
name but he asks what's your dream job
other than youtube how was your first
rejection
and show us your pits if you have any
i'll show you my cat if i manage to
record it like on my phone or something
and i can put it on here for you guys
like right now i guess as i'm talking
his name's jasper and he just jumps
around he's an absolute egg i've also
got a dog and my mom has horses and
stuff my dream job other than youtube i
honestly don't know because this has
been my dream job while i was working in
previous jobs probably a pilot actually
now that i think about it i've i flew a
plane once when i was like 16 or 17 and
that was probably the most fun i'd ever
had in my life up to that point so
probably yeah probably a pilot jaden
twist asks how long did it take you to
hit a thousand subs on youtube i'm not
sure exactly because it was back when i
was like 15 or 16 so that was about
seven or eight years ago but pretty sure
it was like five months or something
like that it was when i was uploading
minecraft hunger games content so yeah i
think it took me around about five
months and i had around 100 videos out
before i had a thousand subs off off
memory off memory but it's so hard to
remember it's like a like a complete
blue now and the kid asks face reveal
question mark
uh i guess that is a a big one if i'm
gonna do that down the line or not
probably in the future for sure but not
until maybe like 100k or something like
that when i can go out and do different
videos that i i really want to do i'm
not sure it's um a lot of stuff there's
a lot of stuff that uh i have to account
for with doing a face reveal
um
and my own personal life and stuff so
it's there's a lot to it maybe you guys
will find out in the future why i'm
saying that and i can't exactly do that
kind of stuff but yeah in the future i
might make a video on it and you guys
know but up until then it's uh i guess
it's all hidden for now and lastly the
last question we have is jackson asking
am i your friend of course he is if you
don't know he's one of the mods on my
discord and if you guys want to go check
it out like i've said it's in the uh
it's in the comment section down below
uh bro everyone on the discord's family
dude so you know everyone join the
discord and become a family let's do it
you know it's how things work around
there also hit that subscribe button as
well become part of passion become part
of the uh the team this is our
organization that we're starting right
here our own little delinquent gang yeah
i hope i could answer as much of that as
i could there are a few things that i
had to leave out here and there because
there were double ups of certain
questions so if i didn't answer your
question
i might have through someone else's
question but there are over 50 questions
alone just on the community post that i
put out not even including if i looked
at videos so that was uh absolutely
amazing so i can't thank you all for the
support it's been an amazing journey so
far and i really can't thank you all
enough as i've said and this is just the
beginning my next score obviously is 20k
but i'd really love to get that plaque
one day if we can ever get there get the
silver plaque 100k i would be absolutely
beautiful but for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo and if
you guys are new around here i'm going
to keep up to date with tokyo revenge's
content and just i guess other anime
content in general then make sure you
hit that subscribe button and also be
sure to leave a like on the video and
check comment down below and let me know
if i should do this every 5 or 10k subs
as i had a lot of fun answering your
questions here and honestly wouldn't
mind doing this again it was extremely
uh interesting and i haven't done
anything like this before so yeah be
sure to let me know anyway i'll catch
you all in the next video bye
[Music]